i had a conversation about this the
other day talking about the difference
between beauty and hotness
now you might have different terms for
it in the literature but uh an immediate
very sexually available signal of
fitness versus a more timeless graceful
more subtle signal of fitness and
i am absolutely adamant that society is
signaling almost exclusively of hotness
at the moment that the inherent
transactional transient nature of most
of young people's relationships where
basically they're masturbating with
somebody else's body
and they just that there happens to be
another consciousness in the room
that that is leading into
hotness being
used as the fundamental cue so look at
i don't even know if these magazines
exist anymore but you know if you were
to get a girl on the front of some lad
mag some boys mag that's got fast cars
and like scantly clad women that they're
not selecting for beauty they're
purposefully selecting for hotness i did
two reality tv dating shows i did love
island and one called take me out
and on that the same
they're not selecting for women that are
beautiful that's not to say that some of
them aren't or weren't beautiful but the
primary value that they're selecting for
is hotness because they only have six
weeks if you only get six weeks in a
villa and you have to share a bed that's
half the number of beds that there are
people so you're sharing a bed with
somebody every night
and they need you to switch switch
he does a two eliminations a week and
all this stuff um they need it need
hotness you can't you can't have
something that takes you three months to
fully appreciate all of the nuances of
louise's
[ __ ] back arch it's like no no no no
the the half sleeve tattoo and the lip
piercing will do it for you straight
away
yeah exactly and
there's an there can be enormous
pressure to kind of signal hotness so i
think tattoos and piercings and certain
kinds of you know dressing in a certain
way
that basically advertises
like i'm you know potentially open to
short-term mating what do you think it
is
what do you think it is about piercings
and tattoos what do you think's the
subtext behind that
i think it's a little bit
it's a little bit culturally
arbitrary
that it it has become associated with
openness to
kind of short-term mating or
you know openness to being open or
polyamorous or whatever
openness to threesomes whatever whatever
you're into
um but once you get the signal
established once there's kind of a
social consensus that
oh if you have a lot of tattoos
that's signaling a degree of sexual
openness that would not be welcome in
salt lake city among the mormons
you know but would be welcomed in like
brooklyn or la or whatever
but i think your point about hotness
versus beauty is is
really
uh
on on the money and
like some women are so beautiful like
whatever cate blind chad or anne
hathaway or certain actresses like that
where it's it's like almost hard to
sexually objectify them
like it feels almost wrong to sort of
put them in the category of like
oh she's so hot
because classy beauty
you immediately think oh i wish i had a
wife like that
right or i wish i had a girlfriend like
that
um
i suspect there's something parallel
with men where like certain men
radiate
kind of like
short-term hotness rather than like good
long-term husband potential
you probably encountered this in the
modeling world a little bit correct and
in the nightlife world a lot dude i mean
because i see
it's so funny you know when you go into
a nightclub and there's a strobe light
on and you don't actually when there's a
strobe light you don't see people move
you see snapshots of the person it's
they're here then they're here then
they're here then they're here um and
running a club night is exactly the same
as that but socially so i only get to
see people for five hours on a thursday
and a friday or whenever it is that your
particular portfolio of events is
running for that season or that year or
whatever and you see
things happen so you'll see
um new group of fresher students arrive
and then maybe this guy and this girl
maybe they meet each other and then
maybe they hook up and then maybe they
start talking and then maybe
they're together for a bit and then
maybe this new girl comes in and but you
don't see everything happen you just see
kind of like this brief window into it
and dude it's so
[ __ ] interesting to see to be able to
select the kids
that are going to be the ones
that are going to have the status that
are highly regarded
and you're right i mean there's
something
there's something around girls that wear
those choker necklaces
that have been accused of being a black
belt for [ __ ] by not me um and
you see that
certain signals play out
and that's what creates the stereotypes
culturally you know you see something it
gets reinforced and then maybe people
see that and think well i've just got
out of a relationship with a boyfriend
why don't i get a nose ring and start
wearing choking necklaces because that's
what the
culture is telling me that sort of
person does and it
it just starts to feed itself
yeah and i think
i would just caution young people like
what you want is you want maximum
flexibility to adjust your signals that
you're sending out
in a way that is like dynamic and
adaptive if you get a permanent tattoo
that's visible
in every job interview
or
at
at your wedding or whatever
like it's hard to go back from that it's
hard to do tattoo removal whereas if
you're wearing you know black belt
choker at least you can take that off
and like then become respectable on
monday don't need to still wear it at
the wedding yeah
so
um
like the of course the more permanent
the signal the more credible a signal it
is because it shows extra commitment
but i think a lot of young people really
like they have a very short term time
horizon and they're really not thinking
ahead about how is this tattoo really
going to look in 15 years
is my future toddler going to make fun
of it
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace